we've already spent a lot of time
thinking about how awesome carbon is for
life that really life as we know it is
carbon based and this all comes out of
carbon's ability to bond with other
carbons and form all sorts of neat
structures bonds with oxygen hydrogens
and other things in fact we have a whole
class of molecules called organic
molecules that just are molecules that
involve carbon and carbon's bonding
capabilities really come out of its
electron structure and we talked about
this in the previous video but if we
think about carbon it has six protons
and a neutral carbon will have six
electrons two of them are sitting in its
innermost shell and then the other four
on its outermost shell and those four
are the ones that tend to react and we
call them the valence electrons and so
these valence electrons tend to form
four covalent bonds for example if you
wanted to bond with four hydrogens well
each hydrogen would contr each hydrogen
would contribute an electron to one of
these pairs which are essentially going
to be a covalent bond
and then the hydrogens the hydrogens can
feel that their outer shell is complete
because hydrogen's just trying to get to
two to fill its outer shell to try to be
a little bit more like helium and carbon
is trying to get to eight in its outer
shell to be a little bit more like neon
neon has two in its inner shell eight in
its outer shell you might remember the
octet rule that that that that
that atoms tried to get to eight or
pretend like they have eight electrons
in their outer shell to feel stable and
here carbon is sharing eight electrons
it contributed four and then the four
hydrogens contributed four and it forms
it forms methane
now those of you who are quite astute
might have said okay well you know what
i i know of other elements that tend to
form four covalent bonds that have four
valence electrons and in particular
there's one that's awfully close to
carbon on the periodic table and that's
right over here this is this is silicon
silicon has 14 protons and a neutral
silicon would have 14 electrons and so
let me draw that so if we have silicon
right over here i'm just going to focus
on the electrons you would have two
electrons sitting in its innermost in
its innermost shell so and they're
jumping around here it's not they're not
these neat well defined orbits they're
just they're jumping around and that in
that in that lowest energy in that in
that in this innermost shell
and then you have another eight in its
second shell
so one i'll just draw them three four
five six seven eight all jumping around
all jumping around in the second shell
as a total of 14. so we already used up
10 so it's going to have four in its
outermost shell
so one
two
three four and these four in its
outermost shell these are the ones that
tend to do the reaction the reacting we
call them valence electrons so if we
wanted to just draw the valence
electrons we could do silicon
has four valence electrons
four
has four one two three four valence
electrons just like carbon has a
different number of electrons these four
valence electrons are actually one shell
further out but it has four that tend to
react and it does tend to form four
covalent bonds so you might be saying
well can't we have life that is
dependent that is silicon based as
opposed to carbon based and if you
thought that you would not be the first
person to think about that science
fiction or authors have have have
theorized that and this right actually
this is a this is a screenshot from the
devil in the dark episode 1967 from the
original star trek where they said hey
they encounter kirk encounters the
enterprise encounters these creatures
that are silicon based they're called
hordas and they have all sorts of
interesting properties so there there's
you know there's some folks who like to
think maybe maybe silicon but when you
actually look at the chemistry things
start to break down a little bit for
example one of the neat things about
carbon is it readily forms bonds with
other carbons and then these bonds can
actually be quite long you can form all
sorts of these hydrocarbons and all
sorts of other
carbon-carbon structures with long
chains of carbon so you can do that with
carbon but it turns out that silicon
silicon bonds are not that strong and
silicon is not going to form is not
going to form really long chains so
silicon is not going to do that
even if you look at a simple a simple
molecule like methane there is there is
a molecule called silane but this does
not readily form it does not have the
same characteristics so this is also not
going to be as good as methane and even
if you think about something like carbon
dioxide which is carbon
which is carbon bonded having two double
bonds
so this is carbon having two double
bonds to oxygens
so two so one double bond to one oxygen
another double bond to another oxygen
and we're used to thinking about carbon
dioxide in our everyday life as a gas
plants are using these to to to fix uh
into their structure to actually grow
they're taking the carbon out of it
their carbon fixation we are we exhale
this carbon dioxide it's essential to
life and you might think well what about
what about silicon oxide and silicon
oxide is actually a fairly common
molecule fairly common compound but it
does not exist in a gaseous state at the
temperatures that were normally that we
normally associate with life most of
silicon oxide is in the form of quartz
in the ground
so that is quartz
over there so when you look at the
actual ways that that that that silicon
forms bonds it actually does not seem
actually close to as good as carbon you
know something like silicon when silicon
bonds with oxygen it's a much not only
is it in this solid form at normal
temperatures
where we normally associate life but
these are very very very strong bonds
much stronger than the bonds that carbon
is forming with oxygen they're so strong
that would make it hard for them to be
manipulated with the types of chemical
reactions that we're used to seeing
inside of organisms so you know it's
it's fun to theorize about this and i'd
be the last person to rule anything out
i think the universe will continue to
surprise us uh with with things that
right now we cannot even imagine but
based on the chemistry we know and based
on life as we know it even though
silicon can form these four covalent
bonds and does have four valence
electrons it's still
nowhere near as good at carbon as in in
doing the types of processes that we
think are necessary for life